ça y est nous a vus par un emplacement
on est dans une zone résidentielle une
zone de riche en activités en bureau en
entreprise donc on a identifié un vrai
potentiel et qui aujourd'hui nous semble
sous-exploité parce que le centre il est
rempli et or un peu plus de la moitié
rempli aux deux tiers et on sait qu'il
ya encore un travail à mener sur ce
centre pour exploiter tout son potentiel
et on va réellement continuer cette
stratégie en s'axant sur le
divertissement sur le loisir et puis
renforcé un petit peu aussi leurs
cravates oration qui accompagnera est la
configuration se prête parfaitement aux
loisirs avec des grandes cellules
disponibles sur les deux premiers
niveaux et pour accélérer leur en place
du centre est espéré à horizon 12 à 18
mois
le remplir à 100% on a identifié
quelques acteurs et avec trois ou quatre
acteurs qui prendrait des très grosses
cellules on arriverait à remplir
l'ensemble du centre